i need to introduce shuji hirahara
who in the last few years
has obtained the sequence of results on
average case complexity which
really changed the picture of what we
thought was possible
and he will tell us about it
today so please sure to go ahead
thank you so much for inviting me it's
great pleasure to present this talk
so today i'm going to talk about the
relationship between averages compressed
and metacompressed
so i would like to start with a very
broad overview on compressed theory and
cryptography and in particular i would
like to explain important fibers and i
think i will explain a recent progress
on the question of excluding heuristic
um let's pretend for a moment that our
world is a value where p is equal to np
then it's quite fantastic in the sense
that if p is equal to mp then you can
solve every problem in lp quite
efficiently there are a lot of problem
in np that we would like to solve
efficiently for example if p is equal to
mp we can do automated theorem proving
in polynomial time
so this is quite fantastic if p is a
good np but at the same time it's bad
thing for us
because
if we consider any public key
cryptosystem we can break it
the security can be broken if p is equal
to np
and recently the value of
bitcoin is increasing and if p is equal
to np then the value becomes zero
because in the system of bitcoin we use
the public key cryptosystem
so the message about this is that if p
is equal to np then our society must be
completely different from what we live
in now
so in order for our society to continue
as it is we need to prove that p is
different from np
but even if p is different from when p
we don't know whether we can construct a
public key crypto system or not
and today's talk is about filling the
gap between feed processing p and
cryptography
and this gap between p person mp
contextual and cryptography was clearly
explained by the celebrated work of
wrestling programs
so wrestling background proposed five
possible word
words that are consistent with our
current knowledge on cryptography and
compressed history so here five first
from algorithmica
up to crypto money
for example
algorithmic is a world where p is equal
to n p
in this world it's impossible to
construct a secure public secure
cryptosystem
and the rest of the world corresponds to
a world where p is different from nlp
and it is
further classified in this way
for example the top most world is called
cryptomania
and this is a world where there is a
secure public g crypto system
most of us believe that our worlds
correspond to crypto money great manual
but we don't know whether it is true or
not
there are other worlds for example there
is a world called the president this is
the world this is the worst possible
world in the sense that in this world
it's impossible to construct a secular
crypto system and
at the same time you can't solve np
efficiently on average
and there is a world called mean crypto
which is a world where it's impossible
to construct a public decryptor system
but you can do minimal cryptosystem in
the sense that you can construct a
secret decrypts cryptosystem
finally there is a world called
heuristic
this is a world where heuristics are
quite efficient
in the sense that they are quite
efficient polynomial time heuristics
that can solve nlp on average
but at the same time it means that it's
impossible to construct a cryptosystem
so so these are five possible worlds
which are consistent with our current
knowledge
and we know that exactly one of them
corresponds to our world but currently
we don't know which world corresponds to
our world
the ultimate goal of compressed theory
and cryptography is to decide which word
correspond to our world
in particular most of us believe that
our world corresponds to kryptomania so
in order by resolving that conductor
eventually we would like to construct a
public crypto system
and we'd like to make our society more
reliable and more secure
so these are quite important open
questions
now what we know about this
well in some sense we have just a
peripheral implication
namely if we have a public cryptosystem
we can construct a secure cryptic crypto
system and if you have a secu secretary
crypto system then we can
show that np is a hard on average
and if np is hard on average then mp is
hard in the worst case
now the compass reaction of these
implications
corresponds to the central open
questions in the theory of compressed
theory and cryptography
for example the bottom blue implication
corresponds to the open question of
probing p is different from np
and if we can prove this we can show
that our world is not algorithmic
in other words we can exclude
algorithmic from five possible valves
similarly if we can prove the second
blue implication we can exclude
heuristics from five possible words
in general if we can prove one blue
implication we can actually
exclude one possible word
and finally if we can prove all the four
implications
we can conclude that our world is
cryptominion and we can construct a
thoroughly secure public key crypto
system
but
these are quite central open questions
in the theory of
compressed theory and cryptography so
there are a lot of work that explains
why standard proof techniques cannot
resolve these open questions
for example
if we want to solve
p
buses and b contexture we need to
develop new proof techniques that
simultaneously overcome relativism our
civilization natural proof barriers
so
standard proof techniques that do not
work and we need to develop new proof
techniques
similarly in order to exclude a
heuristic from five possible world
there are three barrier results
there are division value and the limits
of black box reaction and the
impossibility of hardness application
so in order to make progress it's very
important to develop new proof
techniques that are not subject to these
barriers
fortunately there's a recent new
emerging paradigm for it to be called
metacompressive and i'm going to talk
about what's metacompressed are
so
in one sentence metacompressd is the
complexity of problems asking for
complexity
let me give you one
representative example of
meta completion competition problem
which is called minket
this stands for minimum time bounded
chromocompressed problem
and this is a problem computing with
time-bounded hormone compressed
intuitively
more specifically you are given a binary
string x and you are asked to compute
the minimum program that prints x
efficiently
in other words this problem asks for the
complexity of generating
input x so in this sense this is a
method called metacomputational problems
by considering this method
computation problem
three years ago we were able to show
that for this problem worst case and
averages compresses of minted are
equivalent
more specifically we can show that mean
kt is hard on average with respect to
the uniform distribution if and only if
japanese it's hard in the worst case
and japanese is an approximation
budgeting immediately i will explain the
definition later but what's important
about this is that this goes beyond the
limits of black box reduction
and briefly
limits of black box reduction which was
presented by bogdan hall president
states the following
if we if you have a worst case averages
reduction in np
there are limits
saying that if you have a black box
reduction
the problem must be in np such poly
intersects the coin piece
raspberry and there is a conjecture by
rudy showing stating that gap mean kd
should not be in the problem in core and
visual exporting
so in this sense
this is the first result that goes
beyond their limits
and i will explain the detail
of limits of black box reduction later
but before that let me explain this set
of progress on this research line
um there is um there has been a long
standing opening about the bus yes to
average
averages connection
and there is a compressed class called
the up which is a subclass of np
this is the class that contains for
example integer factorization
now let's assume that up is
exponentially hard in the worst case
can we show that np is hard on average
this has been a long standing of open
question on the relations between
investigates and averages compressed
and the reason is that
there are several excuses for this
long-standing open question for example
if we want to resolve this open question
we can't use a black box reduction to
prove this
similarly there is a standard proof
technique called the hardness
application procedure but you can't use
the hardness application procedure to
improve this implication
it's not clear whether we can apply
relativist barrier to this setting but
in order to resolve this helpful
question we need to do uh
use a proof techniques that
simultaneously overcome these two
barrier results
should we check so you said the
factoring is an example or integer
factorization is an example of a up
problem but integer factorization does
have
like due to the little low end time
algorithms so is there sort of some
other natural problem to which you can
apply this assumption
that would give you hard on average any
problems
yeah actually that's a
very good question and i'm not aware of
a natural problem that satisfy this
assumption unfortunately here i should
emphasize that n denotes the input
length of
other binary
input
so integer factorization can be solved
in sub exponential time in distance
so it's uh
interesting awful question to find a
natural assumption that satisfies this
yeah thank you for the question
um anyway we were able to prove this
implication
and
so we were able to show that if ub
requires the time compressive two to the
little order n then we can show that f
is hard on average
so this statement doesn't refer to meta
compressed at all but what's interesting
is that it's the it relies on meta
computational proof techniques so i'd
like to explain why metacompressd
are useful to studying
averages complexity in a later part of
this talk
but before that let me try to explain
some more recent progress
this
result actually shows that if u p
requires a time compressive two to the
order antibiogram
if it is a quite weird time compressed
we can show that np is hard on average
now eventually we would like to weaken
the assumption to np
the assumption that np is different from
nfp
which would
exclude the heuristic
now
let's consider uh
whether we can slightly improve this
namely can we improve this time bound to
slightly to two to the little order
environment
for this open question um of course we
have limits of blackbox reaction and the
possibility of hardness amplification
but recently it tempered that that there
is a reactivization barrier as well
which we showed in the joint work with
the mixture nanasima
so the message of this is that if we
want to go further we need to develop
new proofs and techniques that also
overcome limits
limitable relativisation proof
techniques
so somehow this we are the time
complexity
terms are to be somewhat optimal in some
sense
um
but there is a
way to bypass relativisation barrier and
we can still make uh
some progress
by considering fine grained fibers so if
we usually consider in particular to
five world we usually talk about
polynomial time adversary as a default
setting
so if we say that there is a public key
crypto system this is a mathematical
statement saying that there is a secure
public key crypto secure against
polynomial time advance rate
but there is a notion called
fine-grained public key cryptosystem
which is secure against
quasi-linear time adversary
and we can draw a similar diagram
to if it is similar to the left
the standard five possible bars
and in this diagram we showed that if
ubi requires a time compressibility to
the order and by n then we show that mp
is hard on average in the usual sense
if we are satisfied with a weaker
conclusion that npe's slightly had on
average
we were able to show that the
assumption can be weakened
namely if you p requires the time
compressive two to the order square
return program
then energy
we were able to show that and feed
slightly on average
so
this very this result doesn't overcome
relativization barrier but this shows
how to bypass relativization value in a
sense
so we can still make folks make progress
on this
difficult question
so
next i would like to explain limits of
black box reduction is there any
question
before that
no you can go ahead
let me explain the details some some
details of limits of black box reaction
well
before that let me quickly remind you
some of
basic standard complexity classes here
you have p and then b and the coin p and
between that you in between you have a
up fit stands for
ambiguous
polynomial time which is a class of
problems survival by a non-deterministic
polynomial time machine
with that has at most one accepting pass
for every input
um you you can understand the compressor
up as a
as a compressive injectable function
there is a nice characterization saying
that up is different from p if and only
if there is a one-to-one one-way
function that is hard to invert in the
last case
and there's a general um generalization
of np which is called ph which stands
for polynomial hierarchy and above that
you have a p space
now let me explain
black box reduction
black box reduction are quite powerful
proof techniques in the context of
what's just averages reduction and
in fact we can prove some several
connections between versus complexity
and averages compressive energy
for example one of the celebrated work
by ite showed that so that
if the shortest vector problem
cannot be approximate in the worst case
then he showed that np is hard on
average
similarly
if we we can reduce statistical zero
knowledge to distributional energy
in the sense that if statistical general
knowledge is not in the worst yes then
the distribution of rp is hard
in the sense that it's not the average p
there's also a simple padding topic
which you can do and
you can actually prove that if np
requires a time compressible tutors
because n
then you can show that np is hard on
average
and these are actually proved by black
box reductions
what do i mean by black box reaction
well this is just a standard reductions
namely if we want to show that some
computation problem is harder on the
easier the the other
we consider an oracle that solves some
problem for example in some problem in
distributional np
and we would like to solve the problem
on every input
for example in the case of statistical
zero knowledge we can construct
constructor reduction
such that for every oracle that solves
some distribution energy problem
the reduction giving requests to a
um it outputs a correct answer for every
input
in this way we can
show the worst yes to averages reduction
so this is a standard reduction but what
i'd like to
emphasize is that
black box reduction doesn't impose any
efficiency requirement on the oracle
when we say
a reduction is non-black box
we say that
we assume that
we mean that the reduction might fail if
the reduction is inefficient
so this is the difference between black
box reduction and the non-black box
reduction
now
the limits of a black box reaction which
was were established by foreign foreign
and border 100 terrorism
shows the following
let's consider any language with any
problem which is outside nfp
sporty industrial connection
philosophy
then you cannot construct any
non-adaptive black box reduction from l
to distribution of energy
in other words
non-black box reductions are too strong
notion to be useful if you want to
get what gets the averages connections
for np
outside co and b strasbourg
so this is a figure here you have an npc
story that's the coin of this raspberry
and it is conjectures that japanese is
outside the rivet
so in order to show what's getting
available connection for
any pro problem outside this limit we
need to
use non-blackbox reductions or
adaptive reductions
and it can be the case that adaptive
reductions are helpful in this context
but currently we don't know any
deduction that goes beyond the limits of
the black box reduction
instead i'm going to show how to use
non-black box reduction and in
particular i'm going to explain why
by using metacompresst we can develop
non-blackbox proof techniques
and i'm going to explain how we can
exploit the efficiency of an oracle
now let me state uh our result and i
would like to explain the details with
the proof techniques and metacompresses
so here is the there are three main
results in the stock paper
the first result
is what we already talked so it's it
says states that if ub requires a time
compressive two to the order and
paragraph then np requires
np is hard on average
and what i should emphasize at the end
denotes the
lengths of inputs if it is encoded as a
binary strings
similarly we can prove that if ph
requires the time complexity of two to
the order n
log n
and then we can say that the
distribution of ph is hard on average
and we can also prove that there is a
worst-case average gas connection for lp
in the sense that if np requires the
time complexity of two to the order in
row n
then we can show that the lp
is harder on average in a slightly
stronger sense
um slightly makes sense um here
average sub pp
denotes pre-computable averages per unit
time which interpolates vast gas
complexity and averages compressed
namely um average sub pp
is a subclass of average averages
polynomial time algorithms and this is
the class of distribution of problems
that can be
solved by averages polynomial time
whose learning time can be estimated in
a sense
more specifically this is a class of a
problem
problem that can be solved by averages
falling over time and we require that
there is an average case learning with
time which up advance the running time
of the algorithm
and the upper bound of the running time
can be computed in last year's
polynomial time
so this is a stronger notion than the
usual averages per unit time but for
this stronger notion we can establish
vast test averages connection for np
of course the weakness is that np
requires
its vast js complexity
but let me quickly mention that we can
prove a slightly stronger statement
but for example you might wonder what
the hard distributions are
actually we can take a quite simple
harder distribution
so the hard distribution we can consider
is the uniform distribution u and the
target distribution which is denoted by
t
so
here t party distributions are quite
simple distribution which is supported
only on a unary input
we can prove that for such a
distribution there is a hard problem
in nfp that is hard on average
and
let me also mention that
instead of hilarious heuristic scheme or
averages polynomial time we can also
prove a hardness for one-sided error
heuristics
namely this corresponds to the hardness
of liftation
and we can also prove that the success
provided is very tiny
namely we can show that there is no
polynomial time algorithm that succeeds
with probability n to the minus c where
c is any constant
um
let me also quickly mention that instead
of up we can consider a slight
generalization which we call size
verifiable np
and this is related to the compressive
imparting of size verifiable runway
function in the last case
anyway let's talk about how we can prove
such vast guest averages
deduction
that goes beyond the limits of standard
proof techniques so the proof techniques
is based on metacompressed
but before explaining meta complexity i
need to explain the time bounded form of
hormonal compressed
t times bounded hormone compressed c of
x is usually denoted by k super square
to t of x and this is defined as the
length of a shortest program that prints
x in t steps
let me give you three simple examples
for example let's consider
the
the complexity of all zero string
then in order to upper bound this
column
the hormone compressive this string we
can consider a simple program
saying that print zero n times
now by considering this program um
the length of this program is at the
most order one plus the binary
representation of n which is fits costly
logarithm so the columnar compressor is
atmospheric and plus order
similarly if you consider the trivial
algorithm that print x
you can show that the time bound for
more compressive x is always at most of
the lengths of input x
and by using a simple counting element
we can also show that there is a
compressed high compressed string and in
particular if you pick uniformly at
random x we can show that even if you
have a time average common complexity
the time bound to
compress this at least n minus 2 with
high probability
so this is the notion
of time-bounded
hormonal complexity
now let's consider metacompressing
which is a complexity of compressed
there are
several
examples of meta computation problems
such as mcsp mjdb and mkt
and in this talk i'm mainly considered
minketty which was introduced by terryco
the this is a problem of computing the
time bounded column complexity
more specifically
um this is the definition of theta
multiple complexity and mean kt is
defined as forwards
the input to the main kt consists of x
which is an input as well as a time
parameter t as well as under size
parameter s
these are represent and call it as a
unary string
and the problem is to decide whether
t time one hormone compressive x is at
most s or not
so in informally this is the problem of
computing the t time bounded common
complexity over x
this is called immediately
and let me quickly mention that there is
a additive approximation button
which is called the gap immediately
this is an older logarithmic additive
approximation by jumping kt
and more formally this is defined as a
promise problem
which consists of yes instances are not
no and no instances
and promise problem is a problem of
accepting every input from yes instances
and rejecting every
no instances
and the yes instances of japanese
consists of the same input to the
magnitude
and knowing instances consists of inputs
whose hormone complexity is slightly
rather than the size parameter
by
additive factor of order login
and here p is some polynomial
and we say that the government
means it is in p if there is some
polynomial that can distinguish these
two sets
anyway intuitively this is just an older
logan additive application version of
minketty
there is a slightly generalized
version of minketty which is it's
usually denoted by minke titus a
which is an a oracle version of minketti
so the only difference between men
getting and making it is a is that in
this problem we are going to
ask a oracle t time bounded to call
hormonal compressed
so what's the a oracle time monitoring
compressor
where
here
the problem you are minimizing
is given access to oracle access to a
and this is denoted by k t
sub squared a
so we get it is a is a problem of asking
the minimum minimum minimum program that
prints x in t steps giving oracle access
to a
you might wonder that a its reduced
vitamin k to the a but currently we
don't know whether it is true or not
and it's easy to see that this is a
problem in np namely in general mean kt
to the a is a problem in um
np20a
but actually it's a long-standing open
question whether
we can prove nfp uh mediat is np hard
one
in fact even if you have a ph oracle we
don't know whether it is np hard or not
so this is
a meta computation problem we are going
to consider
now why is it important to consider
metacompressing well actually we can
exactly characterize averages
compressive ph by using the notion of
metacompressed in the following sense
distribution of ph is in average fee
namely ph is easy on average
if and only if government gated to the
ph is in p
this statement means that for every
oracle a in ph
japanese today can be solved in the vast
case
so japan gets a is an older logarithmic
additive appreciation version of media
to say
so
this characterization
shows that we can understand averages
completely through the notion of
metacompressing
what's interesting about this
characteristic is that as a query we can
get a new proof techniques over
analyzing average gas compresses that
uses metacompressed
let me give you an example
for example by using this
characterization we can prove that there
is a average test hardness application
for ph
and the statement itself isn't so
important but the proof is more
interesting and the proof is given by
going through the notion of what ks
metacompress
memory here i'm writing a statement
about the averages compressed on the
left and i'm going writing a statement
about vast case method compressed on the
right and the proof can be proved by
going through
the notion of whilst yes metacompressd
in this way
you might wonder that this is the tool
but intuitively the reason why it's
um
this makes it easier to analyze is that
in general
um if you compare what's just compressed
and averages compressed it's easier to
analyze whilst it is compressive than
averages complexity
so at the very high level the reason why
this characteristic is useful is that it
makes us
possible
it makes it possible to analyze averages
complexity by the notion of vast yes
compressed
now let's
explain how we can prove the vast just
compressed the connection between the
vertices compresses and
averages complexity
for the purpose of the talk i'm going to
explain the proof of the statement that
if np requires a time compressive due to
the order and paragram then i'm going to
show you how to prove ph is hard on
average
the proof looks like quite similar to
the previous diagram
so on the left so i'm going to write
statement about the averages compressed
and
the proof
somehow goes through the notion of vast
yes metacompressed
in this way
so there is a key notion which we call a
universal heuristic team so let me
explain what the universal heuristic
schemes are
so um before explaining the definition
of
universal heuristic scheme let me
mention that why we call
it universal
so universal heuristic scheme is a kind
of worst case metacompress denoting but
this satisfies the foreign university
so we can prove the following statement
to our equivalent for every
problem error
so the first statement says that there
is a universal heuristic scheme for
error
and the second statement
states that
error can be solved
on average in the sense of a
pre-computative average experiment time
with ellipse with respect to every
polynomial time sample of distribution
so universal altruistic scheme is just
one algorithm but we can show that it is
a good heuristic for every polynomial
time sample distribution
that's why we call it universal
heuristic scheme
now let's give a definition of a
universal heuristics team
well in order to
explain the definition of universal
security let's explain the fundamental
notion of computational depth
computational depth is a very simple
notion but it's a quite powerful notion
which is defined as force
computation depth
c d sufficient t of x is defined as the
difference between t times one
differential complex compressed of x and
the time unbounded hormone compressible
x and we can consider a slightly
generalized version of
computational depth which we call ts
time-bounded computational depth
which is denoted by cd
subscription t and s
this is just the part defined as the
difference between t time bounded
hormone compressed over x
minus
s time boundary to chromo compressive
effects
so that's the definition
now we can define the universal
heuristic scheme
so we say that algorithm a is a
universal accuracy scheme for l
if there is some polynomial p that
satisfies the following two conditions
the first condition says that the
universal heuristic scheme outputs the
correct answer always for every input
and the universal heuristic scheme takes
input text as well as a time parameter t
and you must have to output the correct
answer always
and the question is the running time
and we define that the running time of
the universal heuristic scheme is
proportional to the time
computational depth
namely it must be two to the order of
computational depth of the input x plus
log of t
where t is a time parameter
so in other words the time compressive
of universal heuristic stream is
characterized by the by the time bounded
computational depth
and let me emphasize that this is a boss
js notion in the sense that this works
for every input and this is not averages
notion in this sense
now by using this universal heuristic
scheme i can explain
this part which is quite simple
so what i'm going to show you is that if
you have a universal heuristics team we
are
going to show that there is a efficient
algorithm that can solve
in two to the other environment and
let me explain why this time complexity
appears
so we can prove suffering
if we have a universal heuristic scheme
for problem l
we can show that l can be solved in
slightly faster than two to the order n
the proof is quite simple and i can
explain the proof in this one slide
so the basic proof idea is that we can
take a parameter t so that the
input x becomes
computationally shallow
in the sense that the computational
depth of x is less than order and by log
n
and it's actually easy to prove that
there's a such a computational zero
parameter
in order to show that let's consider the
following simple test scoping sum for
some parameter capital i which is order
logging
let's consider t and p of t
computational depth of x
next let's consider p over d p of p of
the computation of x of x
and
let's continue it until you get the p to
j i of t
and remember let's re
remember that the computational depth is
defined as the difference between time
bounded chromosome processes so you can
cancel out the adjacent terms
now what remains is the first term and
the last term
so the first term is this and the last
term is this
now remember that the computational
depth sorry the time bounded
hormone complexity of x is always at the
most n and it's of course non-negative
so we can bound this by n plus whatever
now if you take the minimum term among
the left hand side
we can find some parameter i such that
the computation depth of x is at most n
by i
so we get some part-time parameter t
such that the computational depth
becomes at most environment
now the reason why we get the running
algorithm that runs into the order and
by the
is that
the universal heuristic scheme runs in
twitter's older environment so this is a
reminder of the definition of universal
jurisdiction
so how can we prove it well
now we can consider the following
algorithm which we call b
the algorithm b
just
takes the universal heuristic
and you run it for several different
parameters t so you start from
summarized parameter t and you next you
simulate it with respect to the timer
meter p of t and p square of t and the
surface in parallel
and you take the first one that holds
and outfit about it outfits
and the proof of correctness is clear
because we require that the universal
heuristic scheme is correct for every
input so this algorithm is is of course
correct
now what about learning time well the
running time
um since we take the first one that
holds we can take the minimum parameter
i
of the running time of the universal
heuristic stream
so it's going to be two to the order
computational depth of x plus log of the
time product
so we have two terms fit unit to balance
and if if you balance this term you can
find that the parameter of epsilon times
log n is the best choice and we can up
around this running time by two to the
order and by looping
so the reason why we get two to the
other environment is that we can find
such a computationally shallow
shadow parameter
now i can explain
how we
can overcame the limits of black box
reduction remember that in order to
bypass the value of black box reduction
we need to exploit the efficiency of an
oracle
in other words
we need to exploit the efficiency of
averages polynomial time which we assume
that it is polynomial time
now if we go through these implications
we can show that
under this under this assumption we can
show that there is a universal heuristic
scheme which lands in time due to order
computational depths of x
and the parameter in the universal
heuristics scheme which is p-prime comes
from the polynomial of the original
averages polynomial time
in this way
if the algorithm is indeed efficient we
can prove this implication and in a
non-black box way
but if it is not efficient we can't
prove these implications
so in this way by using this kind of
meta complexity plus techniques we can
exploit the efficiency of averages for a
long time and therefore the proof is not
subject to the barrier of program and
terrorism
so um
there are several other parts
in the proof but because of the time
constraint i will not explain this but
let me quickly mention how we can
improve this
and in order to construct a universal
heuristics team
there is a notion called the direct
process generated and we combine it
with big symmetry of information and by
using that we can show that if there is
an efficient algorithm that approximate
np oracle time-bounded hormonal
complexity we can construct universal
heuristics team for every problem in np
now for this part which connects
averages compressible ph to vast gas
complexity of np metacompressor energy
we use the notion of direct product
generator again
um since we still have a time let me
explain the notion of direct process and
let me try to give explain how we can
improve this kind of implication
so
there is a very important tool for
analyzing a time-bounded column
compression which we call k-wise direct
block generator
the definition of k-wise direct
generator is quite simple
so
this is the definition of which is
denoted by dp sub t
and this direct pulse generator takes an
input x as well as a seed d1 up to zk
and the output of the director generator
is defined as z1 up to zk
and concatenated with
the inner product between z1 and x and
gk 100x
so this is quite a
simple definition but what what they did
is
well this is actually a pseudo-random
generator construction
that is based on our characteristic
x that extends c's
g by k bits
so
um
what's important about
this
um
kyc um keyword direct process generator
is that it satisfies the foreign
reconstruction property
um we can prove it suffering for every
oracle d and fiber input x
let's say
x
has high chromosomal complexity with
respect to d in the sense that the
common compressible x is greater than k
plus order n
then we can show that this is a secure
pseudonym generator against d
in the sense that we have the following
approximate inequality between two
probabilities
the first
um experiment meant to mean that
the oracle is given
a direct product generate the output of
the direct growth generator as input
and the second explained experiment is
that you were given the uniformly at
random sequence w
and it says that you can't distinguish
w from the output of the pseudonymogen
direct block generator
so what's important about the k-wise
directory
generator is that the otherwise
compressed t is very tiny so it's at
most k plus order wing which corresponds
to this value
and actually this is known to be nearly
optimal
in the context of if you are familiar
with pseudonymous generator in the
context
we usually try to maximize the
extension of the seed but what's
important in the context of analyzing
time-bounded
compressive is to minimize the output so
that the otherwise compressive becomes
small
and these two turned out to be very
useful and let me show you how we can
use this notion to get the worst test
averages connection
namely let me explain how we can prove
that if np is easy on average then
japanese
is in p
um let me explain this in this ones
right for simplicity
i'm going to ignore a time parameter and
let's fix the v something like
polynomial n square or anything
now let's consider the foreign
distributional problem so i'm going to
take some problem in distributional mp
and i'm going to use that algorithm to
show um to construct an algorithm
forming
now the algorithm the problem
distribution problem we consider is
essentially the mean kt problem but we
consider with respect to the uniform
distribution
namely
we pick a uniformly
random input x
and the problem is to decide whether you
can compress it by 2 2 bits or not
namely we want to decide by the
column compressed of x is less than n
minus mass two or not
now let a b
averages algorithm or equivalently
errors heuristic
polynomial algorithm that solves this
distribution problem with high
probability
in other words
um the algorithm outputs the correct
answer or
a special symbol bottom which means the
timer
of the of the heuristic algorithm
in particular we have the following two
properties if it is yes instance namely
if the hormone complexity is smaller
than n minus two
then the algorithm outputs
one or a timeout symbol
and the moreover if you pick a uniform
reaction random input the algorithm out
timers with probability less than little
double 1.
now the reduction that we need
use is the simplest reduction that you
might think of
so here's a randomized algorithm for
solving japanese
t
so you let's say you are given x and one
to the s and you want to decide whether
columnar compressive x is at the most s1
node
the definition of the reduction is
simple
you just
take direct block generator and you
apply
the algorithm a error exclusive
algorithm a on the input and you check
whether it is one or bottom symbol
and in that case we are out of the one
and we do this for our random choice of
g and k where k is
slightly larger parameters and yes
now we need to improve the correctness
of this article this quite simple
algorithm
and in the us case remember that
japanese yes instance is this
so let's say the input can be compressed
to s-fit
in that case we can measure let's
measure um i'm going to claim that b out
of its one
with provided 1
why is this the case
well
let's measure the hormone-compressed
direct procedure generator
then we can upper bound this by common
complexity of x plus the lengths of the
seed
because in order to compute this string
if we are given a program that prints x
as well as the c to z we can compute the
output of the direct vertical generator
and we can if we compute this we can
show that this is at most k plus nk
minus 2 which is the length of the
output of the direct first generator
which means that
this input is a yes instance for the
distributional problem
therefore since this is a
errors heuristic scheme
this algorithm outputs one or bottom
symbol with profit fund
now the more interesting case is that
no case
um in this case we exploit the
efficiency of
efficient efficiency of the oracle a
namely let's say the time bounded column
compressive x is significantly greater
than s which is uh which is close to k
now by using the reconstruction property
of the direct process generator
was pseudo randomness with a direct
voltage generator we can show that
the property that a
outputs one will bottom visibility with
respect to direct progenitor
is close to the probability that a out
of its
bottom symbol is related to the uniform
random w
now if you pick w uniformly at random
you can show that the column compressor
is quite high in particular this is
violated so we can show that this is up
small
so we conclude that the outputs one with
small probability so in this way we can
prove the correct strings and the reason
why this is non-black box reaction is
that this time compressive t prime comes
from the running time of the algorithm
which we assume that polynomial
so the message of this slide is that gap
immunity is a meta computational problem
and by explaining
things that this problem asks for the
compressive generating of x we can
develop a non-black box reduction proof
techniques
so to conclude metacompressed is a
powerful tool to analyze average
compressive especially because it allows
us to
overcome the limit of black relation but
there are a lot of interesting question
and one of the
important question is to develop
non-relativising proof techniques in
this context in particular and
personally i believe that there is a np
hardware industry for japanese which
doesn't really advice
thank you so much for your attention
thank you very much richie for the
talk that include a lot of material
about your work on this so uh let me ask
if there are any questions from the
audience here or from um
the remote audience
yeah so one thing i would like to ask is
so all the results that you presented
are for uniform complexity
and so sort of in crypto it's often
convenient to think about the
adversaries as being non-uniform so for
example
if i want to
start with some problem which is outside
cohen p
which is worst case hard can i get
average case hardness against
non-uniform adversary say if i assume
uniform hardness against the circuits
also
yeah that's a good question
unfortunately currently no
so this only works for like for
even if i don't start with kt but if i
start with some other hard problem
that's about circuits then i cannot get
any hardness results against circuits or
no
uh yeah basically we needed to exploit
the efficient
um uniform algorithm up but
um
red to me mentioned that if we
um if we consider mcsp japanese
we can
construct a
non-uniform
loss together averages reduction so you
can so if we assume that
mcsp is hard for
for circuits then you get average case
gap version is also
hard for circuits
right
if we
assume that japanese
gap msp is hard in the worst case then
um mcsp is hard on average respect
and this this results uh
sort of if i assume concrete hardness of
problems like uh maintain your mcsp
sort of
i mean the results you presented here
sort of you have to start with
exponential hardness to only like in the
worst case to only get like polynomial
hardness in the average case right
but um
say if i if i start with the assumption
that mean kt is exponentially hard in
the worst case
do i get
exponential hardness in the average case
too
uh
yeah for
yeah i guess so because for me kt we can
basically yeah um in the case of
immediately
basically the vast case complexity and
averages compressed are equivalent
in some technical sense so if we assume
that the main japanese is exponentially
heard and if and only if um make it hard
exponentially hard on average
but one thing i should note is that the
time complexity
becomes larger so the gap between s and
unknown instances becomes larger in the
sense that p prime becomes right
but yeah it's possible okay thanks um
any other questions
okay so maybe i can ask one more
question about something that sort of i
i guess i didn't get this part but i
remember that your
initial paper you didn't use this direct
product generator but you used the
nissan victors and generator
so
why why is this better or is it just
better so this part i did not get is
this better just for this specific
reduction or is it sort of does it
always give you better parameters
um
this
basically always gives a better
parameter
because if if you use nissan reduction
generator the otherwise compressing
isn't optimal
um
yeah for this
basically the gap
over yes instances are no instances
comes from the advice comprehensive and
so here in the reconstruction you need
to use less advice to do
yeah this is at least advice that you
can
get
under the advice
so in some sense this is optimal and
this optimality goes to the gap between
yes and chances are no intense so here
the gap is just additive order again and
this comes from the optimality of direct
product generator
okay thank you
well let's thank shuichi again thanks a
lot for
coming to the workshop and for giving
the talk
and we continue tomorrow at